should this hero be hailed instead of
being jailed sadly New York says you
better refrain from protecting victims
on a train yeah Welcome to New York
where your dreams become nightmares and
your nightmares become reality true if
you can make it here it's probably
because you can make a shiv out of a
toothbrush so it's a classic New York
tale of Boy Meets Girl boy tries to mug
girl cops arrest the guy who stops the
mugging earlier this week a homeless
dude apparently held open a Subway
emergency gate for a random woman so she
wouldn't have to pay the fair his goal
to demand money for his service she
didn't pay him so he tried robbing her
then another man notice notices this
pulls out a gun to scare the attacker
away other passengers were so surprised
they actually stopped
defecating the homeless man wouldn't
budge so the gunman ends up firing two
warning shots before the homeless Thug
finally gives up and leaves for his
dinner date with
AOC so the woman was saved and nobody
got hurt the train station got a few few
bullet ho holes but that could only be
an improvement but now the man who
stopped the mugging has been
arrested now the guy in charge of New
York Subway system said quote we don't
tolerate this kind of Conduct in NYC
Transit period Well I think I speak for
millions of New Yorkers when I say
there's a guy in charge of the subway
system so apparently assaulting women is
fine but fire warning shots to save
someone they'll have you in jail faster
than you could say Daniel Penny the
homeless creep was known to police for
being a quote constant problem wow he's
a
[Laughter]
looker
D
but but this is what happens when we
feel there is no law enforcement because
there is no law enforcement the force is
down over 3,000
cops and the ones there have their hands
tied so we got a shortage of cops a
surplus of crazies and Democrat leaders
whose policies give violent nut jobs
free reign If This Were Gotham City
they'd arrest Batman use Wayne Manor to
house migrants and turn the Batmobile
into a
Prius
denan you're from the south so I already
know this answer is vigilantism the
answer I wish it
was um you We call we don't call it
self-defense we call it self-help yes uh
and I've on the show repeatedly talked
about way crazy ways I've tried to come
up with defending myself you know
carrying a hockey stick down the street
or a baseball bat although baseball
sucks so I don't want people to think
that I like baseball um but the only way
of Defending what a leaf blower you
could carry a leaf blower around legal
but damaging right exactly but but the
only self-defense and this is bound to
happen this city will make you insane
and behaving in an insane way and
becoming one of the nut jobs will only
keep the crazy nut jobs away from you
exactly this is why I soil
myself I soil myself on the subway and
all the other weirdos leave me alone
plus I save a lot of time at your
cologne I soiled my yes I Oo we had time
we could stop the show and a skit but
anyway so we predicted this data that
once the left handcuffed the police and
the government allowed deranged people
on the street at some point citizens are
going to have to take the law into their
own hands we don't condone it but what
can you do 100% when when when when the
uh the city and the state don't do their
job and your job is people pay their
taxes uh you know for various things but
one of them is to feel safe when you're
walking down the street when you're in
your home home when you're driving in
your car and when they fail to do that
you're going to get Vigilantes people
don't feel safe people will carry
weapons what's great about this is
finally somebody actually tried to help
somebody else right you know when you
watch the videos of La people just film
it and walk by right this guy actually
tried to help I mean there's I don't I
don't know all the ins and outs did he
have a gun per permit did he have a you
know a concealed weapon probably not in
New York who knows I don't know but uh
it's good to see somebody actually
trying to help somebody else these days
you don't see much of it anymore
[Applause]
yeah all right cat how do you feel about
this like let's say you were the woman
would you want well I had that lady
throw that knife at me when I was in LA
oh that's right yeah this lady threw a
switchblade at me in uh does she know
how work she threw it at me and she said
you crazy and I felt like she was
projecting
cuz she she threw a knife literally at
me and I was with a couple friends and
he we were like is that a knife I was
like yep and then my friend kicked it
away um so he's the real hero so that
she could she was going to go for it
again but then we walked and there was a
security guard I was like Hey that lady
just threw a knife at me he was like oh
I'm sorry like as if I had found like a
hair in my
food um but then he actually went and
handled it and then by the time we got
to our car there were cops there and
they had a taser out and I was like cuz
I was thinking like do I need to talk to
the cops and then I was like oh she's
making a perfectly good case all on her
own yes but in New York sometimes I'll
see these people who are like wearing
masks that I don't think are scared of
coid right like not to profile but I saw
a guy literally on the sidewalk with a M
I'm like I don't think you're concerned
about
germs Todd if you had I think the guy
did have a legally owned gun it was it
was legal so he must have got the permit
years ago and if if you had a lawfully
owned weapon on you and you were
witnessing something like that would you
step in knowing you would be arrested in
this day and age I'd have to think about
it and that's the sad part of it but I
will say if my daughter is on that
Subway and somebody steps in you better
believe I'm paying for every expense
associated with them because I want
people to do that and that forces it on
you do you have the courage to risk
everything thing in order to do it I
have to think that maybe four years ago
I didn't I think now I would because I
have two kids and that changes your view
of the world because you 100% because
you know you would do anything to
protect those kids and that's somebody
else's child and that just changes the
game but all three parts of the story
don't happen in a society where we have
Law and Order if there were cops on that
Subway that woman doesn't jump the Turn
Style that homeless guy is not down
there doing doing whatever he's doing
harassing people and three that
individual doesn't feel the need to
carry that gun because he feels safe in
this city and that was literally Greg
just 10 years ago yeah you know
economically the whole his whole Griff
doesn't make sense how much is the
subway right now 250 250 so is he G to
get anything more than 250 and who's
carrying like let me give you the two
let me give you some quarters with one
of those change yeah I just don't think
it works he's he's not just a criminal
he's not very bright
he'll be our next mayor all right up
next a soccer star spills the beans on
losing to a bunch of teens hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else